zuerst mal okay vom rhein soll ich mir
die augen reinlaufen ja erst mal meinen
augen und dann stellst du dich genau das
brauche ich nicht um
berichtete dass sehr viele auf jeden
fall ich komme jetzt 3 2 1
das war meine ungefilterte erste
reaktion hat sich die vielfalt von
produkten auf dem tisch gesehen habe
meine aufgabe war klipp und klar ich
muss aus diesen ganzen produkten ein
eigenes gericht kreieren und damit
herzlich willkommen zum video leute ich
sag's euch so viel es hat mich wirklich
herausgefordert an meine grenzen
gebracht ob ich das geschafft habe und
wie das ergebnis ist könnt ihr selbst
herausfinden indem ihr das video schaut
viel spaß damit ich kreiere mein eigenes
gericht auf den ersten blick habe ich
keine ahnung was überlegen und ich
musste mir was überlegen ich meine seht
ihr in diesem tisch der ist prall
gefüllt ich habe mich quasi meine
kreditkarte gegeben erst einmal fett
shoppen gegangen hat den gesamten tisch
mit produkten gefüllt und es war jetzt
an mir etwas zu überlegen was zusammen
passt was sinn ergibt was den roten
faden habe ich meine ich habe unmengen
von sachen und die musste ich einfach
irgendwie zusammen fügen ich muss jetzt
wirklich erst mal gucken was ich mir
hier raus ziehen anspruchs ja auch heute
was möglichst neues zu erfinden nicht
einfach nur ein gericht daraus zu kochen
weil sonst würde ich mir eine pasta
machen damit speck und rosmarin so das
ist ja nicht mal ein anspruch etwas
eigenes kreieren so weit wie es geht
also ich werde auch kein rezept
zurückgreifen und das ja das schwere so
weil wenn ich die süßkartoffel anschauen
und denkt in der süßkartoffel pommes
oder eine süßkartoffel geräten schon
hast du so eine bekannte sache aber ich
will jetzt heute möglichst viele neue
sachen machen diese unfassbare vielfalt
von lebensmitteln hat mich wirklich
erschlagen so ich wusste gar nicht wo
fange ich an was passt zu was und wo
kommt dann die dritte vierte fünfte zum
tathergang stetig die qual der wahl und
langsam langsam langsam hat sich ein
bild herauskristallisiert meine
herangehensweise sich gucken wir jetzt
sachen an und gucken was ich mit denen
außergewöhnliches machen kann und
probieren sie dann zu kombinieren mit
dem model habe ich eine idee wie ich sie
anders einsetzen kann als nudel das
nehme ich auf jeden fall dann glaube ich
ist eine gute herangehensweise so eine
sens zu erstellen also quasi ein ich
glaube ich verwende avocado spinat und
schönes grünes avocado spinat der gast
so schwer das ist wirklich so schwer so
ich habe einen kranz ich habe das war
dann also meine bisherige ausbeute aber
erst dann wurde mir bewusst dass ein
gericht ja am besten so in sich komplett
sein muss dass muss verschiedene
komponenten verschiedene
geschmacksrichtungen abdecken damit es
funktioniert und um das zu verstehen um
das anzuwenden musste ich wirklich quasi
über alles was ich im letzten jahr so
gelernt habe einmal nachdenken da im
kopf im sternerestaurant ich habe
gekocht für leute ich bin einmal alles
durchgegangen und langsam hat es klick
gemacht so ich probiere jetzt quasi ein
herzhaftes gericht zu kreieren so
mittagessen abendessen wie auch immer in
meinem kopf geht direkt ab ich brauche
eine beilage ich brauche eine
proteinquelle und ich brauche was frisch
ist so ich habe jetzt quasi als frisches
in form von dem öl geschmacklich
zumindest und den kranz der englische
text uhr gibt das heißt ich brauche
etwas proteinreichen und ich brauche
irgendwas kohlenhydrathaltige
froh dass ich das so oft schillig zu
hausen haben kann weil trotz diesem
geilen setting entsteht in wir so
eindrucks oder das ist schon was geiles
machen will aber wenn ich wenn mir zur
dachbox rezept einfallen würde das wäre
ja heftig so wie oft kriegt man davon
mit dass es ein neues rezept gibt
überlege gerade mache ich irgendwie so
bacon rappt irgendwas ich muss noch ein
bisschen weiter überlegen ich sage es
ist und ganz kurz das der grund das habe
ich gerade hier sitze und das
nachträglich erzähle konnte ernst nicht
konzipieren und moderieren das habe ich
gesagt scheiß drauf ich erzähle dass das
wissen hat okay leute ich hab nicht ganz
krank idee denn das zusammenkommt so wie
ich mir vorstelle wird es über sky aber
sagen aber nicht zu viel es brauche
dafür auf jeden fall eine variation von
gemüse relativ gut zusammenpasst wo man
muss schiffchen daraus machen können
dann braucht jetzt nur um ein protein
scheiß drauf wir brauchen eier und bacon
wir werden hoffentlich sehen und
verstehen warum das alles machte aber es
ist so eine herausforderung wenn eine
herausforderung sucht dann macht das ja
dann kann jetzt basic die eigentlich
alles weg also vielleicht gerade ich
noch mal so zur zubereitung auf ein paar
sachen zu aber an sich war es dass sie
und ihr denkt euch jetzt vielleicht ok
mit dem paar zutaten kann das noch
nichts besonderes werden und das habe
ich auch gedacht dass ich gesagt habe
dass wir alle zusammen habt kommt der
fall ich habe wieder alles anders
überlegt die beiden kommen zurück ich
brauche jetzt aubergine lammkoteletts
tomaten und zwiebeln kommt einfach
darauf entsteht weil er erst einmal
alles weg räumen was wir nicht mehr
brauchen würden und dann wurde es
wirklich ernst ich habe angefangen zu
kochen zuallererst nudeln über braucht
also statt elf minuten 35 minuten um
danach knusprig chips daraus zu machen
dann habe ich mir meine lammkoteletts
und den bacon geschnappt und parallel
dazu noch mal diese ganze vielfalt
gesichtet die ich hatte das grüne das
gemüse und es sieht schon so sehr sehr
gut aus muss ich sein logischerweise
habe ich einen neu erfunden das gericht
noch nie gekocht plane aber in einem
topf damit kleine masse entstehen zu
lassen die sehr geschmackvoll mit lamm
arbeiten mit aubergine tomate zwiebel
und natürlich ein paar kräutern um diese
richtig schön zu aromatisieren und
reichhaltiges wird zum püree sein wird
es so ein tabu sein wir werden es habe
er hinter dem was dabei rauskommen aber
ich muss jetzt erstmal anfangen wenn
nämlich von unseren lammkoteletts hier
nur den fleischanteil einarbeiten und
das fällt natürlich trotzdem schön
auslassen und geschmack geben lassen und
das habe ich dann auch gemacht denn
fleischanteil aus den lammkoteletts
rausgeschnitten dann das fett getrennt
knochen getrennt weil wir wollten
natürlich trotzdem alles verwenden und
das war ein bisschen arbeit ging aber
wenn es gut und jetzt erst mal auffallen
die wenig eigentlich an so im land
komplett dran ist und hier sind unsere
drei endprodukte das feld das wir
auslassen werden der knochen der
geschmack gibt und das fleisch das dann
am ende in unserer masse drinbleibt
gesagt getan wir haben das fett
ausgelassen und ab diesem moment hat die
ganze küche ist so gut gerochen kann man
sich einfach nicht vorstellen
seitdem wir die nudeln aufgesetzt haben
sind 35 minuten vergangen und sie sind
nicht fertig gekocht sondern über kocht
ihr seht das auch wieder jetzt wackelt
so das ist glaube ich eine sache die
jeder italienischen honor ganz ganz
traurig macht wir mussten das tun haben
ein bisschen öl drangegeben seien
paprika- das ganze einmal schön
durchgemischt also schnappen wir uns das
ganze und geben es in den backofen bei
200 grad aber die werden nicht lange
allein im backofen sagen ja wird
bestimmt gefragt was macht ihr mit dem
vacant und ich hatte eine ganz besondere
idee ich habe irgendwo im entfernten
winkel von meinem kopf mich erinnern ich
habe mal einen bacon cup gesehen also
dass jemand ein becher oft wegen gemacht
hat das wollte ich machen und musste
dafür erst mal formen bauen also taste
genommen mit alu folie ausgekleidet
diese neue schale quasi einmal ausgelegt
mit becken und ab zu dem passt chips in
den backofen und wie das nun mal mit so
einem becher mit einem cup ist das was
drin ist zählt aber dafür müsst ihr euch
noch ein bisschen gedulden damit der
bacon und die passt da nicht so allein
sind im backofen dachte ich mir dafür
kürbis und nicht irgendwie ich habe
erstmal ausgehöhlt und habe dann eine
tür bis spalte daraus geschnitten nicht
einfach so sondern mit ganz gutem grund
denn sie ist quasi das kernstück von
unseren gericht dass wir heute erstellen
und die habe ich jetzt schön eingeölt
wenn man sie nicht austrocknet im
backofen und mit dazu gegeben das schon
irgendwie geil also es kommt so
stückweise alles zusammen man hat sich
etwas überlegt wirklich auch wie ich
finde ihr werdet sprecherin der relativ
kreative idee es scheint alles zu
funktionieren
das ist wirklich sehr schön die spannung
es da bleibt das so wie ich mir
vorstelle und wer nicht wie kann ich es
retten so weil das sind gerade die
sachen die mich am meisten beschäftigen
weiß auch nicht leute es ist eine ganz
außergewöhnliche situation aber es macht
eine menge spaß es ist ein bisschen so
wirklich wie sie zu malen oder erfolg
also du hast die einzelnen farben vor
der linie und ja der tellers
zieleinfahrt sie muss halt irgendwie
etwas überlegen und es muss sinn ergeben
so genau wie so eine ausländer muss muss
das gericht zusammen und all das feld
das sie jetzt im top sie ist nicht
nachträglich hinzugefügt sondern das kam
raus wirklich aus den lammkoteletts aus
dem fett was wir abgetrennt haben und
aromatisiert diese gesamte masse die da
jetzt entsteht zwiebeln anbraten dann
das klein geschnittene fleisch von den
laden komplett mit dazu geben dann haben
wir darauf gewürfelt schiene gegeben und
cherry tomaten aber nicht frisch sondern
tomaten aus der dose die sind nochmal
ein stückchen aromatischer gerade im
winter und haben unsere masse einfach
einen richtig schönen körper gegeben so
das ganze nochmal aromatisiert mit
thymian rosmarin ein bisschen köcheln
lassen aber gewendet und ihr seht schon
die maske wurde immer dicker und dicker
und zum ende auch komisches wort jetzt
stand fest aber warum wir das brauchen
werdet ihr sehen was hier eigentlich
durch alle edlen restaurants zieht sind
mit denen die arbeiten selbst
hergestellte die automatisiert sind und
das stelle ich jetzt mit spinat er ein
spinat öl das auf dem teller schön
aussieht und noch mal so eine feine
leichte frische note hinein gibt hat
einmal den spinat er habe in meinen
messbecher sagt das sind 60 gramm etwa
und darauf gebe ich jetzt 30 gramm und
ich sage mal ehrlich so möhl insofern
sie restaurants und dill oder so macht
schon wirklich viel her und man denkt oh
mein gott wir können kraft kochen aber
ich habe herausgefunden ist gar nicht so
schwer man friert einfach keinen anteil
öl und zwei anteile kräuter kocht das
ganze bei 80 grad ein bisschen auf und
presst es dann durch ein tuch und dann
hat man dieses öl was ein instant
glauben es dass leute krass kochen
können also kleiner life hätte ich auch
gelernt habe und das war somit fertig
sieht ein bisschen aus wie ein bastelset
was ihr hier zusammen gezaubert haben
das werde aber ich kann mich so viel
sagen ein schritt fehlt noch ich war
noch einmal passieren und dann sind wir
fertig und jetzt was zeit alles
anzurichten zunächst einmal habe ich
einen setzling auf den teller gepackt
damit klar ist wir haben es hier mit
einem gericht zu tun den habe ich
ausgefüllt mit unserer ragout masse oben
quasi eine schöne kannte gemacht das
ganze hochgehoben und es ist stehen
geblieben das war unsere erste große
angst hat aber funktioniert dann habe
ich darauf unsere spalt oder besser
gesagt unser schiffchen aus hokkaido
kürbis gesetz darauf kam dann unser
bacon cup und auf den bänken cup das
passiert was ist das für ein bild ich
sag's euch es wird entstehen sobald
dieses spinat will dazu kommt wir haben
quasi
mehr aus spinat öl dann haben wir einen
felsen aus baku darauf ist ein
gestrandetes schiff was natürlich von
unseren vorherigen ehe mit der mit
american cup gefahren wird das war
wirklich das ding ich habe mir gedacht
okay ich will so etwas machen wir
sowieso ein schiff dann mache ich das öl
soll es mir und alles weitere hat sich
dann so ergeben und ich meine man
erkennt dass jetzt vielleicht nicht und
wenn ich mir so angucke finde ich auch
eigentlich dass es nach oben hin zu
großes oder cup ist ein bisschen zu groß
und so weiter und so fort aber dieser
ganze kreative prozess für ein gerechtes
finde ich schon cool ich bin auch sehr
stolz darauf aber die wichtigste frage
ist natürlich wie schmeckt das ganze hat
jetzt auch sinn gemacht das ganze zu
kochen schaut euch an wie wunderschönes
geworden ist sind jetzt zerstören wir
alles wieder nur für diesen moment
unsere masse die erste gabe von einer
eigenkreation
du glaubst nicht die präsent dass spinat
öl in der gesamten rechnung ist aber es
ist auch wichtig weil das dieses
herzhafte der herzhafte masse ich habe
keinen namen dafür dann hast natürlich
bacon so du hast ganz ganz viele das
sehr herzhaft schmeckt und dazu
[Musik]
noch eine große portion geworden am ende
jedenfalls eine sehr große portion das
war gerade noch aus was sticht heraus
bei jeder gabel was andere und dass das
keine es ist halt auch durch beim besten
willen nicht ungesundes oder sondern man
hat das gefühl man ist was richtig
frisch ist ich bin überrascht wird alles
also macht sinn außer der crunch sind
die pasta chips noch einen einfach mal
zum klassischen dienstag im gericht
erfinden wer kennt es nicht leute es hat
aber wirklich unmengen spaß gemacht und
das produkt war nicht nur schön
anzusehen sondern auch lecker man hört
euch an was eric dazu zu sagen hatte
macht sowas gerne auch mal falls ja
täglich darin danke fürs zu sehen und
bis zum nächsten mal
manteks gar nicht ganz locker wer das
schon mal auf dem teller hatte er lügt